enfin une histoire pour terminer ce
journal celle d'une très vieille dame il
s'agit de la vénus hottentote smart en
1816 et bien sa dépouille mortelle vient
d'être rendu officiellement à l'afrique
du sud après avoir passé près de 30 ans
au musée de l'homme à paris
c'est le résultat de plusieurs années de
bataille virginie timothy kaine un
visage et un corps devenu historique
saartjie baartman mieux connue comme la
vénus hottentote n'avait que 27 ans
quand elle est morte
c'était en 1816 après avoir été exhibée
en angleterre et en france comme une
bête de foire est un objet de curiosité
sexuelle
si son corps a traversé les siècles
c'est toujours en étant exhibé mais
cette fois ci dans un musée d'histoire
naturelle de paris
le moulage de son corps et son squelette
ils sont restés exposés jusqu'en 1974
une dépouille symbolique que l'afrique
du sud réclamée depuis six ans et qui
vient de lui être rendus man est devenu
un symbole pour le peuple sud-africain
le symbole d'un pays qui a besoin d'être
confronté et de connaître son passé un
passé et un thé d'esclavagé de
colonialisme hier par cette cérémonie
solennelle presque un hommage religieux
l'afrique du sud a voulu réaffirmer sa
dignité une dignité dont la vénus
hottentote se fait désormais le symbole